Film Courage: Peter when we first met you
(I believe it was 2014 in the summer time),
so it’s almost been four years now exactly
and we heard from you (in this interview)
and it’s done incredibly well (as all of
your’s have) but this I’d love to play
it for you if you don’t mind?
Peter Russell, story doctor, instructor and
screenwriter: Sure.
Film Courage: Great.
I know this sort of feels like a Senate Hearing
but it’s not.
Peter: I didn’t do anything criminal.
Film Courage: Good.
Peter: I remember that.
I’ve got my lawyer in the back.
Film Courage: Good.
No this is about…we will keep in on screenwriting
here.
And we have a great clip to play, so here
we go.
[Audio]
[Peter Russell from our first interview in
2014 at Story Expo entitled I Don’t Enjoy
Writing Screenplays]
“That I’m no good at it.
The reason that I’m a teacher and a consultant
and a story doctor is that my big secret is
that I don’t enjoy writing screenplays.
I tried for awhile to do it, it’s not my
thing.
If poetry paid, I’d be in the chips because
I’m a poet because that is what I love to
write and I also like to write novels.
But years ago the reason I became what I am
is because years ago I failed to complete
a screenplay.
It got huge interest and I realized at the
end of it was I don’t like this form, it’s
just not for me.
I love analyzing it, I love understanding
how it works, I love helping other people
do it but I don’t enjoy sitting down and
writing a screenplay form, it’s not my thing.
Film Courage: Okay, great.
So that was four years ago.
And what I’ve found from an email from you
is that you’ve actually completed an historical
TV series.
Peter: Yeah and I still hate writing.
Film Courage: Okay, so nothing has change.
Peter: I’m always going to hate it.
I was just telling Suzy yesterday “Gosh,
I hate this!”
But I’ll tell you yes, I’ve had some success
and what’s great about that is…here’s
the really great thing, when you’re a teacher
you don’t really know for sure…my stuff
actually helps, actually turns out to work.
The stuff I’ve been teaching actually has
helped me which is a huge relief because when
you’re a teacher you are often up there
and it’s easy to pontificate “Oh do this
and try this tool.”
Some of my tools were terrible, but a lot
of them actually worked.
But I still hate writing and that’s always
probably going to be the case and I think
maybe there are some writers who don’t hate
writing, they just love it.
“Oh, I can’t wait to get to the desk.”
But I’m always going to loathe it.
I guess I’m good enough at it to get paid
and so I’ll do it.
It’s actually fun to get paid.
And it’s fun to know that your stuff is
actually going to be out there but yeah I’ll
tell you something else I’ve been consulting
and ghost writing and story doctoring and
teaching for 20 years.
And I quit writing, I quit the whole idea
that I was going to write at least 6 times
“Screw this!”
And I meant it.
“This is terrible, it’s awful.
I’m never going to succeed and I stopped.”
And I stopped, I stopped for at least a couple
of years.
And I did that several times because the process
of writing is so excruciating I think for
me and other people.
I have to say my lovely bride Suzy is a very
successful writer in South Africa.
I hope she doesn’t mind me telling this
story but she is very successful in South
Africa.
She has her own column and she’s created
her own voice.
She came here and she started studying television
(she’s frowning at me, I probably shouldn’t
say this).
Anyway, my Gosh this is hard!
And it is hard.
The film and television structure is difficult,
it’s a difficult form to master and it has
so many different components to master.
I think if you’re a writer (if you are a
novelist), it’s difficult.
All writing is hard, but with television and
film it’s excruciatingly complex, there
are so many moving parts to that it may be
one of the harder writing forms.
And it was certainly the case for me and that’s
the case so yeah I stand by the fact that
I hate writing.
Film Courage: So what changed (sorry to interrupt),
what changed for you from the time we shot
that interview?
Peter: I guess I got people who wanted to
pay me to co-write with them as opposed to
story doctor and so because of that…and
I also found the right partner…here this
is critical especially when you are writing
in television and film.
I know people who do it alone and they are
great, I don’t know how that’s even possible.
I highly recommend that you get a partner
(a writing partner).
I’ve had a couple in the last year that
have been marvelous.
And when you find the right partner it’s
almost like you’ve gone from the single’s
bar to a couple, it’s like “Oh, yeah!
I love you.
I want you here and you can help and I’m
not alone.”
And that’s really what it feels like.
And also they admire you and they tell you
you’re great.
And you need someone telling you you’re
great, when you’re a writer because you
feel like crap all the time.
And you are also getting producers and managers
and agents whose main job is to tell you you’re
crap, that’s what they do.
“This is crap!”
This is pretty much…just put that on auto-play.
“Oh, my manager is calling.
What are they going to say?
They are going to say this is crap.”
And that’s what they do “This is crap!
How dare you.
I just talked to someone about this story.
Well they say this is crap, Peter.
It’s absolute crap.”
And I have to say again, that is also what
you’ve got to get used to in the commercial
field which is also I think William Goldman
said this a long time ago and I didn’t realize
it, he said everything is a piece of sh*t.
When they refer to your script, they may have
bought it for a million dollars he said “Hey,
I just read your piece of sh*t.”
Or “We are filming your piece of sh*t next
week.”
And it’s a piece of sh*t, right.
So anybody who feels like “Well I need to
be validated and I need to be affirmed”
he should not go into Hollywood writing business
because whatever the culture that originated
in Hollywood and I think it was and I think
it was a bad deal for writers back in the
30’s (we gave up our birthright for sod
pottage), where we said “Hey, we don’t
need our name on it.
It’s not our movie.”
Whatever happened back then there’s a toxic
relationship that was commemorated back then
by the writer and the producer.
And the relationship was the producer is in
charge and the writer is sort of servile and
they’re going to get the abuse and whenever
there is a problem, it’s usually a problem
for the writer.
It’s not the producer’s problem, it’s
the writer’s problem, he just didn’t write
it well enough.
So you are going to get a lot of criticism
and abuse even when they say they like your
thing, even when they buy your thing, it’s
still going to be “It’s a piece of sh*t.”
And that just sort of what it’s been like
in my experience.
So you need to writing partner to grab your
hand “That’s okay darling, yes we are
great aren’t we?
Yes we are, it doesn’t matter what they
say.
Yes, we’re great.”
And that’s what writing partners can do
for you.
I highly-recommend, do not do this alone.